now i know how winter can be really
tough on the skin
and you're in the cold so much and we've
teamed up with
olay body and they have some great
products for winter right
yes i've been using the olay body washes
and i love them they really hydrate and
visibly improve my skin
through the cold weather and i've
noticed they
well one they smell amazing but they
really i can
feel and tell my skin feels so much
better than other body washes i've tried
you know
we actually have somebody that we're
going to bring into this
we have this viewer and she needed a
little help keeping her skin hydrated
and she certainly has my heart her name
is rhiannon from aurora illinois
hi rhiannon how are you hi drew
it's really nice to meet you um likewise
oh thank you i very much admire you and
what you do will you please tell us
about
it well i am a mail carrier
in aurora illinois so i deliver mail
one letter at a at a time well i am a
big
fan of um the usps
i am a big fan of snail mail and what
you do is so important
i also wanted to ask you a quick
question which was
you said you deliver the mail one letter
at a time and it's
some of your customers that keep you
going and mean the most to you
yes well i think uh one in particular
really spoke to you didn't they
yes uh i had one customer that i i
delivered to
and um that ended up being my husband
um so uh we are now
i've been working for the post office
for 13 years and i met him when i first
started
i delivered that letter to him and
um he uh he just stole my heart
and he said that i delivered with a
smile so um
he knew when he was going to marry me i
love your story so much
and i know working in chicago especially
in a time like winter
i mean pun intended you must face a lot
of cold winter days
how do you get through it what is your
regime and routine
i'll tell you it it takes a lot of
layers
um a lot of uh protection on the skin
because uh the weather takes a a major
toll on me
you know the wind right 40 below
yeah i can't think of a you know more
amazing aficionado about winter and
weather and what to do and how to do it
than jamie
so rhiannon i know that you have been
sent a special care package
from jamie yes jamie what is in there
yes i wanted to send you some really
warm and cozy stuff
to help you enjoy the winter we sent you
some warm gloves
thick socks a hat and a selection of
olay body washes
these are made with really great skin
care ingredients like
vitamin c and hyaluronic acid but guess
what
olay is also sending you a whole year
supply of
products and walmart is going to be
giving you a 500
gift card yay thank you
thank you well and because olay body
is sold at walmart we're sending our
vffs a
50 walmart gift card today
i know it's my happy place well thank
[Music]
you
you